[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique est elle devenue une lutte
générationnel les deux tiers des moins
de 30 ans considère l'écologie comme un
enjeu primordial
un jeune sur cinq se déclarent prêts à
risquer sa vie pour sauver la planète
chez les adolescents de moins de 20 ans
c'est un sur trois mais ils ont
l'impression de ne rencontrer
qu'indifférence de la part des
générations plus âgées surtout celles
qui ont grandi durant les trente
glorieuses ces fameux boomers qui ne
veulent pas entendre parler de
décroissance ni changer de mode de vie
alors trop catastrophiste les jeunes
trop radicaux bien ce sont les plus âgés
qui sont dans le déni qui ne veulent pas
voir l'évidence pour en débattre j'ai
invité trois activistes de l'urgence
climatique de moins de 30 ans et comme
j'ai le double de l'orage on va pouvoir
se demander qui de ou deux mois
représentent le plus grand danger pour
l'avenir de cette planète julien vesnina
vous avez 28 ans vous êtes le fondateur
de wings of the ocean une association
française de dépollution des océans et
des plages fondeur 2010 8,7 l'auteur de
pourquoi tout va s'effondrer c'est paru
la même année aux liens qui libèrent
les boumeurs sont ils un danger pour
l'avenir de cette planète à votre avis
c'est pas forcément les boumeurs mais
c'est le niveau de vie des uns des
occidentaux de plus de 60 ans qui est
aujourd'hui un problème pour la survie
sur la planète toit des plus de 60 ans
bat de toutes les personnes qui ont un
revenu d'au dessus de 2000 euros par
mois donc
s'accordent plus de 50 ans objet même 40
ans parfois non ouais la plupart du
temps c'est mais comme les revenus
augmentent avec l'âge ouais c'est à
partir de 50 ans qu'on est vrai qu'on
est vraiment après c'est juste que la
prise de conscience est de plus en plus
difficile en avec avec l'âge moi j'ai vu
mes parents ils ont maintenant chiffrés
mais ils ont mis un temps fou à le faire
et je vois la génération de mes grands
parents c'est encore plus compliqué donc
toute cette génération de boomer
effectivement c c'est difficile de leur
faire prendre conscience de chez
fondremand notre civilisation et camille
etienne vous avez 23 ans vous aussi vous
êtes une jeune activiste de l'urgence
écologique porte parole du mouvement de
vidéastes on est prêt membre du duo la
pensée sauvage fanny tic le faire vous a
classé parmi les 50 françaises qui ont
marqué l'année 2020 et vous êtes vous
avez été la rédactrice en chef invitée
du hors-série de social terre
intitulé l'écologie ou la mort les
boomers c'est une menace
pour l'avenir de cette planète a va
travailler on se définit les boumeurs
comme les personnes qui sont attachés à
un vieux nom de corps et âme qui ont
confondu les croyances avec des vérités
qui sont les limites planétaires qui
sont l'extinction de singles à la
sixième extinction de masse qu'on est en
train de vivre ça c'est des choses avec
lesquelles on peut pas mener de négocier
et à l'envers cboe marque pour moi c'est
les personnes qui décident de ne pas
négocier avec une croissance infinie
dans un monde fini aux ressources
limitées qu'on mesure est uniquement par
le pib si on définit les boumeurs comme
ça dans ce cas oui c'est une menace qui
pèse sur la survie de l'humanité est
principalement de ma génération qui va
connaître les catastrophes croissante
bien gilbert vous avez 27 ans vous êtes
consultant prospective et risques
climatiques conseiller scientifique à
l'institut rousseau un laboratoire
d'idées en faveur de la reconstruction
écologique et démocratique vous êtes
l'auteur
livre j'ai au mimétisme réguler le
changement climatique grâce à deux grâce
à la nature qui est paru au petit matin
même question les boomers ont peut être
un jeune urbain aujourd'hui avoir un
bilan carbone désastreux parce que bon
on prend l'avion c'est pas cher pour des
week end à marrakech ou que sais-je ou
parce qu'on est hyper digitaliser et on
parle pas souvent du poids carbone de
l'informatique mais c'est énorme donc
non pour moi le vrai problème il et puis
il se situe plutôt du côté du
verrouillage du jeu politique par les
personnes plus âgées c'est à dire que
c'est les personnes plus âgées qui sont
le socle électoral de ce bloc libéral
conservateur qui est incapable de régler
quoi que ce soit en termes climatique
qui est incapable de faire bifurquer
l'économie vers vers le bas carbone
l'électorat socle des manuels macro et
de valérie pécresse qui constituent ce
bloc libéral centriste c'est ce sont des
gens qui sont plus âgés que la moyenne
pour moi le voilà le vrai problème il
est plutôt là pareil je le rappelle vous
avez le droit de vote pourquoi vous
votez pas mais c'est vrai que si on
couple l'aspect démographie avec la la
discipline de vote c'est-à-dire que les
personnes âgées sont des gens qui sont
beaucoup plus fidèles beaucoup moins
abstentionnistes que ma génération et
malheureusement il faut il faut aussi
qu'on soit capable de remobiliser
mobilise électoralement notre génération
mais
aussi parce que les débats ne sont
absolument pas sur les sujets qui nous
intéressent enfin je veux dire quand on
voit la qualité des débats qui a eu des
candidats ou des candidates
le débat de la droite pas 2h15 à peu
près de débat pas une minute où il pas
une seule fois où ils ont prononcé le
mot écologie donc bon on parle
uniquement de la dette de l'immigration
c'est pas là dessus qu'on doit aussi
mobiliser la jeunesse donc il faut être
capable de parler des enjeux réels qui
intéresse notre génération pour qu'on
puisse ensuite mobiliser les jeunes à
aller voter c'est la responsabilité elle
est partagée
par commande accord aujourd'hui dans le
programme de fillon en 2017 il y avait
c'était la 18e seulement mesure qui
était une mesure écologistes il y avait
les 19 20 et 17 à d'avant on avait un
n'avait rien à voir donc non aujourd'hui
moi je me ressens je meurs je me
retrouve absolument pas dans tout ce que
on va retrouver vers la la droite le
centre et à l'extrême que j'en parle
même pas mais
je sais pas si c'est vraiment quelque
chose de générationnel ou cissé
c'est juste qu'aujourd'hui moi je
m'intéresse de moins en moins à la
politique politicienne et je m'intéresse
de plus en plus par contrat au
militantisme de terrain à être avec
notre association fait de la dépollution
tous les jours et on récupère du
plastique sur les plages on essaie de
bouger localement en fait vis-à-vis de
différentes mairies et trouver un relais
politiques enfin dans de la politique
localisé là on a des relais mais au
niveau de tout ce qui est politique
nationale on n'a pas vraiment de l'eau
justement vous savourez la question de
se poser si vous deviez faire un
programme politique qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait changer là maintenant tout de
suite d'après vous qu'est by etienne
le vrai et programme idéal mois pour la
réponse allait dans la démocratie et
donc le fait que ce que moi qu'elles
détiennent une étudiante de 23 ans pense
finalement assez peu d'intérêt par
contre 456 toit s y soit citoyenne tirés
au sort qui sont posé la question
pendant plusieurs mois c'était la
fameuse convention citoyenne pour le
climat qui ont auditionné tout-etat
d'espèces d'experts est d'ailleurs pas
que des membres du giec et une galerie
masson delmotte et puis aussi le
président d'un grand groupe d'agro
industrie et ils ont ensuite fait des
débats démocratiques et sont parvenus à
149 mesure que la france pourrait mettre
en place dès aujourd'hui pour limiter
les émissions d'au moins 40% d'ici 2030
et astérix importante sans laisser
personne derrière c'est à dire vraiment
dans une logique de justice sociale donc
moi si je devais être à leur place déjà
je respecterai ces mesures-là
kindle on les a tous subi par exemple je
vous invite à aller voir le site emprunt
c'est assez intéressant et ça montre
bien aussi l'intelligence collective
parce qu'il y en avait qui étaient même
climato sceptiques au début ils ont été
tirés au sort donc c'est pas que des
militants et les mesures sont finalement
assez ambitieuse il ya par exemple
l'interdiction des publicités sur les
produits polluants pourra arrêter de
dire que c'est les gens qui décident de
même d'acheter des choses et que donc la
responsabilité est individuelle
ban en réalité quand on dépense des
millions d'euros en marketing et en
publicité pour créer dire clairement le
choix il est dirigé donc par exemple
c'est ça ou c'est mettre dans toutes les
cantines que dans toutes les
collectivités et ben un menu une options
végétariennes serait simplement une
option sur les sols et transport aérien
qui a limité les vols à interdire les
vols intérieurs qu'un alternative en
train de moins d'aimer sans que c'était
2 ou 4 à
14 soit encore mieux parce que j'ai
vraiment pas très long enfin je veux
dire à un moment donné si on vit dans
une urgence telle qu'on n'est pas
capable de prendre en 32 heures un
moment donné qui est une question
fondamentale de de mode de vie
occidental à se poser aussi bien gilbert
moins compliquée cette question mais
c'est dans la droite ligne de ce que dit
camille moi je pense que c'est retrouve
reprendre le contrôle sur sur la vie
économique puisque on souffre de
l'inertie d'un système économique qui
qui n'est pas régulé du tout donc qui
est basé sur des énergies fossiles à
tous les échelons que ce soit
l'industrie que ce soit la finance aussi
très imbriquées et si on si le
gouvernement se donne pas les moyens de
reprendre le contrôle là dessus par
exemple en fixant des normes donc en
s'émancipant aussi ça peut être de
certains traités par exemple les traités
de libre-échange les traités européens
voilà si on si on ne reprend pas ce
pouvoir là on va pas pouvoir faire grand
chose mais si je peux reprendre sur le
les aspects au niveau des générationnel
les grandes entreprises capitalistes en
fait aujourd'hui elles sont aux mains de
personnes qui sont dans cette génération
entre 50 et 70 ans et si c'est cette
génération en fait c'est le la personne
ring qui est tourneur fraiseur dans une
usine et qui à 50 ans c'est pas elle qui
va être la principale cause du
réchauffement climatique par contre le
pdg de n'importe quelle entreprise
pétrolière l'est
le pdg de n'importe quelle entreprise
qui gère une industrie florissante la
plupart du temps c'est pas des gens qui
ont en dessous de 45 ans et donc du coup
qu'ils sont enfin cesser cette
génération-là capitaliste qui est qui
est aux manettes et qui eux doivent
prendre les décisions et qui aujourd'hui
ne les prennent pas du tout quoi
finalement la fracture n'est pas tant
générationnel que dans les inégalités
sociales il les incarne presque encore
plus fortement on a tous les rapports
d'octane dernier sorti a vraiment
quelques jours sur le fait que c'est un
tout petit pourcentage qui contient le
plus de richesses qui est en plus de sa
responsable d'une immense majorité des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
c'est le cas au niveau français est
d'autant plus exacerbée au niveau
mondial encore faut-il croire les
rapports auction vous êtes sérieux
ça me regarde et d'autres à former
en ce qui concerne la décroissance on a
eu l'impression véritablement alors avec
le avec que la crise du que vides et
notamment le premier confinement le plus
sérieux on a eu l'impression d'une sorte
de répétition générale et les gelées me
semble-t-il particulièrement dans votre
génération ou tout à coup vous êtes dit
et vous nous l'avez fait entendre
d'ailleurs vous voyez on peut le faire
quand on veut on peut le faire on peut
arrêter les avions on peut arrêter les
camions partout on peut faire tout ça
donc c'est bien la preuve que c'est
possible
et en même temps peut-être que les plus
âgés se méfie ils n'ont pas forcément
bien vécue même si c'était doux calme et
puis enchanteur
mais ils ont sans doute moins bien vécue
que vous et ils se disent bientôt on va
pas refaire sa phase est l'équivalent de
ça tous les ans pendant 30 ans qui nous
faudrait 6 parce que c'est ça la
décroissance se serait mais ça voudrait
dire aussi maître kung des tas de gens
au chômage et puis à la fin qu'on
s'entretue tous parce que soit on n'a
plus de travail soit on n'a plus
d'argent soit on n'a plus à manger
n'importe eu lieu à 2 degré il en
faudrait 1 supplémentaires tous les ans
une décroissance de 5 % par an on sait à
peu près ce qu'on a eue avec le vide et
avec la première année de covin c'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire tous les ans en
plus pour tenir les trajectoires à 2 à 2
degrés donc donc fait là où je parle de
répétition générale on a eu une petite
idée quoi moi je pense que c'est un
c'est un très mauvais parallèle
effectivement si on si on s'embarque
dans ce genre de rhétorique on n'en sort
pas parce qu'on fait fuir tout le monde
le problème c'est que voilà c'est des
émissions qui ont baissé de manière
quantitative parce qu'il ya eu moins
d'activité mais la question c'est pas
c'est pas une la quantité d'activité
c'est plutôt la qualité c'est à dire que
tant qu'on fait pas dix furent quais
notamment l'industrie parce que voilà où
la finance sur des modèles qualitatif
qui sont décarbonés intrinsèquement
parce que on utilise des matériaux bio
inspirée dans l'industrie parce qu'on
oblige la finance à ne financer que des
activités hors des fossiles on n'y
arrivera pas mais ça ça donne un horizon
de société extrêmement positif
extrêmement stimulant si on végétalise
aujourd'hui les villes pour les rendre
plus vivable et plus plus fraîches en
temps de canicule c'est aussi plus beau
c'est aussi une meilleure respiration
des villes qui sont plus oxygéné qui
sont moins brillantes et si on n'arrive
pas à montrer ce récit ce récit
désirable effectivement on va faire fuir
tout le monde kabyle était aussi savoir
que pour moi le sel parallèle valable
avec avec le confinement s'est en effet
celui de dire c'est possible c'est à
dire que constamment avant cette
pandémie on venait dire quoi ce serait
peut-être pas mal quand même de faire
quelque chose et on nous disait donc
vous êtes bien mignon vous êtes jeune et
alors vous savez c'est compliqué c'est
une grande machine c'est un grand talent
ce bar on ne peut pas faire ça voilà
c'est trop lourd c'est une sorte
d'inertie du système bizarrement quand
il ya une menace qui pèse sur l'humanité
là on est capable enfin
méditer sur ces fuites sur les plus
faibles aussi il peut y avoir des
défunts des personnes vulnérables et des
comorbidités qu'ils sont jeunes et
qu'ils sont aussi minable ça ne concerne
pas que les personnes âgées mais donc du
coup ça c'est peut-être le seul
parallèle par contre ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que nous ça ne dépend pas de nous
mais c'est parce qu'on souhaite moi si
on me demandait je serai je serai
absolument ravi qu'il n'y pas de
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
et nini social et environnemental ce
serait merveilleux simplement ce sont
des faits voilà c'est très clair
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on fait et ce
qu'on décide d'attendre et de devoirs
comme avec une pandémie les subir ou est
ce qu'on décide de choisir cette
condition est donc potentiellement de
protéger tous les plus précaires qui
risquerait de trinquer dans ces
situations là pourquoi ça a été
difficile pour quoi on a eu des
étudiants qui ont fait la queue aussi
pour eux qui n'ont pas forcément tous
bien vécu un d'étudiants qui ont fait la
queue balade alimentaire bas parce que
ça a été subi que c'est une crise qu'on
a dû d'un coup comme ça très rapidement
prendre des mesures à très court terme
c'est aussi possible de d'anticiper
c'est ce qu'on propose de faire une des
catastrophes et notamment des pandémies
parce que ces pandémies là et on en
parlait dans le social terre avec
seulement il parle du sexe des pandémies
c'est à dire que on va entrer dans une
ère de pandémie et que
l'artificialisation des sols engendré
l'élevage et tout un tas de choses
engendre ces zones au ski sont des
maladies transmissibles à l'homme et
c'est peut-être que les premières nous
on propose au contraire de de prévoir
plutôt que de faire que de guérir en
dernier recours pierre gibert le plus
intéressant avec cette pandémie c'est
qu'elle elle a montré la fragilité du
dogme qui nous qui nous en lacets avant
c'est-à-dire typiquement la rigueur
budgétaire c'est 3% de déficit public
maximum imposées par l'union européenne
d'un coup on a eu l'argent magique or
pour réaliser notre transition
écologique il nous faudrait au bas mot
100 milliards d'euros par an rien qu'en
france d'investissements publics et pas
que public mais supplémentaires parce
qu'il faut faire changer tout l'appareil
de production parce qu'il faut qu'on
passe à l'agroécologie etc donc on voit
bien que là pour le coup c'est possible
encore faut-il avoir la volonté se
réapproprier politiquement bas les
moyens de cet argent magique et donc
peut-être de remettre la main sur la
banque centrale européenne par exemple
mais c'est aussi se poser la question en
fait est-ce que ce modèle là combien
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est souhaitable
c'est souhaitable pour une partie de la
population qui est bien heureuse mais ça
c'est pas du tout le cas ton on va les
inégalités explosent et on voit comme je
rappelais les étudiants les étudiants de
faire la queue pour avoir accès à l'aide
alimentaire fin on en est là quoi je
veux dire qu'actuellement peut-être que
demain un monde plus juste socialement
et écologiquement serait peut-être plus
souhaitable pour une majorité de
français et de françaises c'est aussi de
sa compagne c'est ce que y'a pas
aujourd'hui des raisons quelque part de
s'indigner et donc de souhaiter un pâle
à autre chose qu'il dit effondrement
climatique ou non on peut le voir aussi
les choses autrement c'est le
réchauffement climatique c'est d'abord
un problème d'énergie on va être tous
d'accord à peu près là dessus c'est
d'abord l'énergie qui pose un problème
or c'est avec les énergies fossiles
qu'on a pu depuis 200 ans en devenir 7
milliards c'était pas gagné qu'on a pu
tout à coup fabriquer faire fonctionner
de plus en plus de machines qui nous ont
permis de nous nourrir de mieux en mieux
parce que c'était pas gagné non plus il
ya sûrement tiers de cent ans de nous de
nous rire de nous chauffer de nous
déplacer et de travailler au fond on a
eu besoin des énergies fossiles pour
tout ça pour arriver à 7 milliards sur
cette planète qui parviennent plus ou
moins bien à tous ces résultats
on a l'impression que si on doit
renoncer aux énergies fossiles
c'est revenir de 100 ans en arrière
c'est revenir à l'époque on ne vivait
que avec des énergies renouvelables donc
on se chauffait on se déplaçait grâce au
vent et au soleil
est ce que ce serait pas le retour
d'injustices et d'inégalités qui était
bien plus grande il ya 200 ans où il ya
300 ans qu'aujourd'hui ouais mais on a
encore un petit delta pour on a encore
un petit delta des missions possibles
pour tenir les deux degrés qui nous
permettrait de faire cette transition
justement pour arriver à une 1 système
qui poule qu'ils soient le moins
inégalitaire et le moins entre
guillemets pourri possible
lorsqu'on va arriver au moment où on
n'aura plus droit d'émettre de co2
vincent pas cessé de degrelle
là aujourd'hui on a encore la
possibilité de faire cette transition
dans plus on attend et plus on reste
dans un déni climatique comme on est
aujourd'hui dookie hôtesses qui feront
parler d'égalité d'injustice que les
énergies fossiles sont là la grande
cause qui va sauver la justice sociale
et au contraire non je dis packers amal
sauver je dis que c'est ce qu'il a
permis à un exemple très concret
travaille sur un projet de pipe line
n'accepte ni coop qui est entre
l'ouganda et la tanzanie le plus grand
lot du show fait donc le délire c'est
quand même que c'est aussi grand en
question partait de bruxelles à madrid
est en fait c'est chauffé parce qu'on
doit chauffer à 50 degrés pour que le
pétrole puisse à transporter donc ce
merveilleux projet soutenu par total et
politiquement par emmanuel macron qu'il
a félicité le président ougandais lors
de sa réélection sur ce projet des
places déjà des milliers de familles en
ouganda et en tanzanie menace la
sécurité alimentaire de ces personnes là
parce que il détruira aussi le lac
victoria menace directement même l'accès
à l'eau de ces personnes et là c'est un
projet pétrole et donc en fait quelle
qualité parce que il permettrait
d'enrichir pour une grande majorité
total est très très peu des revenus
regardait réellement pays dans des pays
qui parfois peuvent être corrompu et
donc en fait l'argent ne ne vas tu ne
profite pas réellement à plus de justice
sociale c'est aussi simple que ça
finalement gilbert bon le charbon le gaz
le pétrole c'est 70% des émissions
d'humanité chaque année donc oui c'est
le problème principal effectivement ces
énergies fossiles ont permis un saut un
développement technique un développement
humain qui est inédit qu'il faut
reconnaître pour la simple et bonne
raison que 1 litres de pétrole chaque
nous ça contient autant d'énergie que 10
employés qui travailleraient par exemple
dans le btp pendant toute une journée
donc on voit se développer beaucoup plus
sûr dans certains domaines exactement
mais canalisée par des machines on voit
l'explosion en termes de capacités
productrices que ça pu offrir à
l'humanité sauf que maintenant ça nous
permet aussi de développer des
technologies par exemple les énergies
renouvelables mais qui peuvent nous
permettre de le substitut et quelque
part ces énergies fossiles et on
n'aurait sans doute pas pu développer
des panneaux solaires extrêmement
productif par exemple à plus de 20 % de
rendement des éoliennes qui fonctionne
convenablement de la marée motrice etc
si on n'avait pas eu ce passé industriel
la fossiles mais
l'enjeu ça va être effectivement
substituer n'ont pas accumulé les
sources d'énergie comme c'est le cas
actuellement mais croyez vraiment là les
et les allemands le d'ouvrir la nouvelle
coalition allemande promet je crois de
de passer à 80% de d'énergies
renouvelables d'ici 2030 c'est possible
dit il faut y croire du tout mais
personne n'y croit ils ont arrêté le
nucléaire ils l'ont remplacée par des
centrales à charbon ce qui est une
catastrophe pour pour le réchauffement
climatique et vous pensez vraiment que
même encore en consacrant deux ou trois
pour cent du territoire de l'allemagne
ce qu'ils ont promis 2 à 3% avec des
éoliennes ils n'arriveront jamais à se
passer du charbon ou du gaz enfin gérer
l'intermittence en fait mais excédé a
nagé qui sont intermittentes donc à
partir du moment où il n'y a pas de vent
il faut savoir juste se dire que le
train de 8 heures ne part pas à 8 heures
et il partira le lendemain sauf
qu'aujourd'hui notre civilisation est
incapable de gérer ça donc elle et elle
veut pas elle veut pas le faire sauf que
la transition effective ce sera
peut-être à terme de se dire ok les
trains partiront quand on aura de
l'énergie et ce sera peut-être ça une
génération en 2060 2070 qui arrive à
tourner avec une un semblant de confort
ce serait ce genre de choses on peut se
déplacer quand le il ya du vent vous
n'avez pas l'impression que sa vie votre
génération est plus prête à l'entendre
que la mienne oui c'est ça c'est juste
que
franchement ouais y'a pas de on n'arrive
pas à comprendre l'urgence c'est ça qui
m'exaspère un petit peu c'est qu'on ne
comprend pas l'urgence de ça et
aujourd'hui toute la flotte à la voile
elle a toujours fonctionné nous on se
déplace à la voile schering et on se
déplace quand ya du vent et s'il ya une
tempête on attend le lendemain pour
partir et c'est pas grave en fait on
arrivera quand même à bon port et
on décale un petit peu notre programme
et c'est pas très grave
gilbert il ya une règle d'or pour
réussir sa transition écologique c'est
plutôt un triptyque c'est qu'il faut
faire de l'efficacité c'est à dire que
tous les tous les usages d'énergie qu'on
peut épargner on le fait il faut faire
de donc ça c'est la sobriété de
l'efficacité c'est à dire que plutôt que
d'avoir un suivi d'une tonne 8 pour
transporter 80 kg de deux personnes et
bah allez sur des voitures beaucoup plus
légères beaucoup plus petit avec des
matériaux biosourcés ours et on sait
faire ça très bien et donc beaucoup
moins de consommation énergétique et
puis ensuite il faut substituer les
sources d'énergie et pour ça il faut
cultiver une biodiversité solution
personne ne dit qu'on va remplacer
toutes les centrales nucléaires par que
des éoliennes ou que des panneaux
solaires en france non mais en allemagne
en mai 19 mais même en allemagne c'est à
dire qu'on peut jouer sur beaucoup de
paramètres effectivement on a des
sources diversifiées de nerfs que ce
soit le solaire l'éolien le marémotrice
j'en passe et des meilleurs mais il faut
aussi jouer sur la gestion de la
consommation en modulant grâce aux
réseaux intelligents ou smart grids le
moment où et puis il ya la question du
stockage qui qui va avec la question de
la consommation et les étude de l'ademe
montre que c'est peut-être 30% on peut
on peut voir un peu substitut être enfin
on peut aligner à hauteur de 30% la
consommation avec la production
électrique si on agence bien les flux ça
ça veut dire développer des capacités de
stockage qui techniquement en fait sont
à notre portée ça peut être l'hydrogène
ça peut être même les barrages step ça
peut être même des micros des micro
batteries par volant d'inertie ou que
sais-je les solutions techniques on les
a mais des tendances il fait très froid
en comme en ce moment par exemple on
arrive à être chauffée tout le monde bah
oui parce que enfin prenez juste
l'exemple des chauffe-eau on a tous un
chauffe-eau de chez nous le ch le
chauffe eau si vous le branchez quand ya
une surproduction de nerfs quand les
éoliennes tournent la nuit et que
personne n'en consomme pour faire
chauffer votre eau bon bah vous avez une
petite réserve d'énergie qui peut vous
durer toute la journée pareil si vous
bloquez votre votre lave linge
pendant les heures creuses a et c on
peut moduler donc on peut casser les
pics de consommation qui sont le soir en
hiver quand demande aux rentrées allume
son chauffage ça on peut le faire par
contre il faut effectivement un peu de
volonté publique derrière parce qu'il
faut remplacer les chauffages
électriques il faut aussi utiliser le
big data quelque part pour optimiser
tous ces flux l'a donc mais savoir ce
que se dit de beaucoup de bonheur quand
ils vous entendent ils disent mais
pourquoi on a peut-être nous un déni en
fonction ce qui concerne le
réchauffement climatique mais pourquoi
chez vous et chez la plupart des
écologistes en france 1 et pas seulement
en france pourquoi un tel déni sur le
nucléaire c'est la seule énergie
décarbonée véritablement efficace et
vous voudriez à peu près tous la voir
disparaître pour un hypothétique
absolument pas monsieur 100% pour
nucléaire est clairement dans le sens où
fin c'est l'une des énergies sur
lesquels quand j'ai commencé à militer
pour le climat il ya 5 6 ans j'étais je
regardais ce que le faisait les autres
écologistes mais j'avais je
m'intéressais un petit peu la question
est très vite j'étais contre le
nucléaire puis après il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de vulgarisation scientifique
qui sont passés dessus et aujourd'hui
moi je le vois vraiment comme un
amortisseur de la décroissance c'est à
dire que c'est on il ya beaucoup
d'écologistes qui voit le nucléaire
comme la première énergie à fermer mois
pour moi c'est d'abord le charbon
à peu près je crois 70% des français
croient que le nucléaire fabrique des
gaz à effet de serre et je crois que
c'est dans votre génération les 18 34
ans c'est 86% 86% crois que le nucléaire
fabrique envoi du co2 dans l'atmosphère
oui il ya personne qui vient rapport de
la ville un projet
bien sûr que c'est pas irréaliste tout
de suite de d'arrêter toutes les
centrales et deuxièmement c'est quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comme une énergie
décarbonée mais simplement ça pose aussi
des questions en termes d'humanité de
dire quels risques on est prêt à prendre
quels risques on est prêt à prendre
aussi pour refroidir les centrales dans
un monde où y est on en stress hydrique
où il ya des canicules ça pose aussi
tout un tas de question qu'on doit se
poser démocratiquement en fait c'est une
question qu'on doit se poser
démocratiquement en ayant accès aux
bonnes informations donc dit comme
beaucoup malheureusement comme dans tous
les sujets il ya beaucoup de faits que
news à propos de ça mais c'est important
aussi de ne pas en fait c'est ce qui
m'énerve un peu connus clair c'est que
celle dambach non seulement des discours
c'est à dire que ç'a vraiment
cristallisé l'intégralité des débats des
présidentielles l'écologie résumé au mot
nucléaire on a confondu les deux mots on
parle que de ça donc un moment donné
c'est important la question de l'énergie
mais il ya aussi une biodiversité qui
est en train de s'effondrer un rythme
aussi rapide que les ors de la 5ème
extinction là évidemment personne n'en
parle la justice sociale c'est pas très
grave non plus on parle juste de la
survie des gens met donc à un moment
donné moi ce qui m'énerve un peu avec
cette question c'est que bien sûr que de
manière transitoire on en a besoin
ça pose quand même des questions de
gestion des déchets des questions de
sécurité qu'on ne peut pas juste décidé
comme ça d'homère ça fonctionne et de
l'amfar fait fonctionne ça a fonctionné
par ya quand même quelques quelques
personnes vous allez leur dire ça je
pense qu'ils s'adorent marqué des
générations aussi les cours bat contre
genk claire oui plus que les années
n'ont pas été justes c'est le prêt
[Musique]
l'actualité économique de la semaine
décryptées par olivier delamarche le rsa
remplit-il ses objectifs non à en croire
un rapport de la cour des comptes
comment voulez-vous avec un peu plus de
500 euros vous en tirez et vous loger et
c'est donc évidemment que c'est pas un
tremplin pour quoi que ce soir je pense
que le dispositif aurait eu une
efficacité si on était dans une
économie réellement solidaire pour à
l'édition 2022 choose france 21 projets
d'investissements ont été annoncées en
france il ya une contrepartie qu'on va
promettre à des entreprises si elles
viennent s'implanter que d'abord on les
embêtera pas trop sur les licenciements
qu'ils annonceront après et vous aurez
une une déduction fiscale ou des aides
pour vous installer pendant une période
donnée méfiez-vous qu'on l'appelle pas
bientôt loose france aussi
[Musique]
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille et en 2030 il y en
aura plus de 100 milles autour de la
terre le secteur spatial est un domaine
stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaire essentiel de
laventure c'est pas tellement laventure
scientifique et c'est d'abord une
recherche de supériorité stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec julien vanni
dzack à 28 ans l'auteur de pourquoi tout
va s'effondrer avec k bis etienne qui à
23 ans la rédactrice en chef invitée du
magazine du hors série du magazine
social terre intitulé l'écologie ou la
mort et avec bien gilbert l'auteur de
géo mimétisme réguler le changement
climatique grâce à la nature
on se pose la question de la dangerosité
de la menace que représentent les
boomers sur l'avenir de cette planète
mais aussi la menace que par la même
occasion vous pouvez éventuellement
représenter l égard de l'avenir de cette
planète parce qu'après tout on a
l'habitude de se poser la question
quelle planète allons nous laisser à nos
enfants mais peut-être faudrait-il se
demander à quel enfant allons nous
laisser cette planète
par exemple l'agriculture parler de
biodiversité mais on sait que il ya
l'énergie qui est responsable du du
réchauffement climatique mais aussi
l'agriculture l'agriculture c'est une
vraie importance on sait que rien pour
les français par exemple il faudrait à
peu près diviser la quantité de viande
et de laitages par deux ou trois pour
espérer rentrer dans les dents les
chiffres que nous conseille le giec
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire là aussi là maintenant
tout de suite est-ce qu on rationne
oui oui oui carrément oui on va tuer car
non en fait on arrive à très bien vivre
végétarien fin en en étant végétarien
des compléments alimentaires non
végétariens non megan vega nuit le
beidou c'est le seul complément
alimentaire qu'on donne actuellement
déjà aux vaches parce que les temps non
plus également je les granules donc en
fait c'est soit on les donne directement
aux gens sont les donne aux bétails donc
c'est pas julien surtout pour que nous
imposer le végétarisme à tous où
en vrai oui en vrai il en fait c'est ce
que je fais sur les bateaux de higgs
dans le sens où dès le départ en fait
les règles du jeu quand on quand on
monte sur des bateaux là aujourd'hui on
était enfin celle de l'année dernière
mais c'est 70 personnes dans
l'association les 70 personnes mangent
végétarien sur le sur les bateaux de
l'association est en fait même pour ceux
qui ne sont pas végétariens la base
sur le temps qu'il passe avec nous ils
le vivent très bien à partir du monde
c'est bien cuisiner c'est tout le monde
le vit très bien et ensuite enfin moi je
n'empêche pas que derrière on en a eu
enfin quelq'un harris se manger une
entrecôte dans un dans un resto mais
c'est assez frais par contre sur nos
bateaux non et aujourd'hui je vois pas
pourquoi
genre dans les cantine d'école il y a
encore de la viande je veux dire si
jamais on a envie de considérer que la
viande est un choix de luxe et qu'on a
envie de militer pour de la bonne viande
si jamais on pouvait appeler ça comme ça
pour moi c'est juste ça reste des
morceaux de cadavres d'animaux mais
sinon si on veut militer pour la bonne
viande en fait on devrait arrêter d'en
manger
6,7 fois par semaine en fait on devrait
arrêter la plupart de nos repas carnés
donc tous les repas en collectif devrait
être sans viande et sans poisson
aujourd'hui on est en train de
complètement défoncée parce qu'il a pas
d'autre mot que de défoncer complètement
là la biodiversité océanique moi je suis
toujours dans les océans et il ya il ya
c'est extrêmement compliqué de faire se
rendre compte à la population le
le désastre et le massacre qu'on est en
train de faire aux océans est
aujourd'hui moi quand je vois qu'à paris
on mange des soucis c'est complètement
une aberration on est en est à 300 ou
350 km de l'océan et on peut manger du
poisson quand en moselle chez moi chez
mes parents il y a de temps en temps du
saumon ou du saumon fumé c'est une
aberration on est à 700 km de l'océan a
claqué mentor des romains sous
l'antiquité on mangeait du poisson à
paris
oui mais sauf que du temps des romains
il y avait 200 millions d'habitants sur
l'entièreté de la planète aujourd'hui on
est 8 millions 5,8 milliards 5 pardon
enfin les limes
la quantité de poissons mangent et n'a
rien à voir en fait on a une demi heure
ça tout à l'heure j'ai 17 milliards et
demi mais on est aux alentours de 8
milliards de bahts ans je vais
rationnement
sur cette question de l'agriculture en
fait si on parle strictement climat
manquent pas morale etc il faut qu'on
divise par trois notre consommation de
produits carnés mais pas moins parce
qu'on a besoin de l'élevage dans les
cycles agricole donc c'est à dire un
élevage extensif qui est imbriqué dans
les cultures était pas
concentrationnaire comme il l'est
actuellement pourquoi parce que c'est
les sig de la zot du potassium et
caetera et que c'est comme ça que nous
on fertilise
parce que ça c'est une question morale
qui sont
alors ça c'est une autre question c'est
une question éthique mais je rentre pas
dans ce débat-là une je ne parle
seulement je ne parle que climat et
après ce que ce que disait julien est
intéressant sur d'une part le
conditionnement parce que c'est vrai que
à la cantine on conditionne et petits à
des habitudes qu'ils auront toute leur
vie donc mangé beaucoup beaucoup moins
de viande et de la meilleure viande
puisqu'en fait avec ce régime a tout le
monde s'y retrouve sur les amateurs de
viande en fait ils ont de la viande de
meilleure qualité beaucoup moins mais de
meilleure qualité reste donc le
conditionnement à l'école restauration
collective et puis effectivement ce qui
culturellement et valoriser on est dans
une culture mondialisée à mettre fin
américanisé où effectivement netflix et
les sushis c'est in et c'est instagram
able alpha là où ça pose le plus de
problème c'est les produits transformés
plus que les sushis c'est les produits
transformés les produits industriels a
bien sûr alimentaire est une question de
flux effectivement parce que si tu aimes
en deux manches des soucis voilà ça
donne des élevages de saumons
concentrationnaire sur toute la côte
norvégienne qui est en qui sont en
surcapacité et ne s'est pas du tout
soutenable par rapport au milieu
océanique locale donc non il ya
effectivement comment est-ce qu'on rend
culturellement désirable des menus qui
sont beaucoup moins impactants thermique
en même temps comment on explique
à la fois aux commerçants ce qu'ils nous
vendent les fromages la viande les
charcutiers les bouchers
et fromagers
comment on explique aux agriculteurs
ceux qui pratiquent l'élevage etc c'est
qu'ils n'auront plus de travail
justement ça c'est la vie la vraie
question à se poser c'est la plus le
plus importante aussi c'est se dire
qu'il ya eu de la même manière en fait
qu'on a essayé de déplacer le débat
écologistes la responsabilité sur les
individus qui a été aussi très
orchestrée en par un coca cola qui sait
des grandes campagnes pour dire ah là là
mais c'est vous qui ne jetez pas votre
bouteille dans la bonne poubelle
vraiment vous n'êtes pas très sympa et à
aucun moment je te dis spéciaux n'en
vend des pluies y avait eu aura pas eu
tout ce que vous pouvez pas demander à
nicolas d'arrêter tour du coca cola
comme coca cola a prononcé un mot débat
coca cola mais il ya quand même des
populations mexique sans cristobal de
las casas n'ont plus accès à l'eau parce
qu'ils payent à une production de coca à
côté fins on en est à ce niveau là quand
même de n'importe quoi mais ça pose des
questions de droits humains aussi ses
coentreprises en mai mais au-delà de ça
en fait sur l'agriculture de le
parallèle que je voulais faire avec le
déplacement de responsabilité c'est
aussi qu' on a essayé de monter les uns
contre les autres c'est vraiment le
diviser pour mieux régner des
écologistes et des agriculteurs
c'était moi mon premier sujet
d'engagement est ce que j'essaie de
montrer c'est que personne n'est gagnant
de ce système aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
c'est décidé à la pac et pour moi c'est
vraiment à ça quand on parle
d'agriculture et d'alimentation qu'on
doit s'attaquer cette fameuse politique
agricole commune dont la france est le
premier bénéficiaire est en fait ce qui
se passe c'est que on a un tiers des
agriculteurs français qui gagnent moins
de 350 euros par mois donc en fait si on
leur dit vous arrêter vous n'avez plus
de métier en fait sur leur propose un
multi qui a du sens ce qui serait en a
vraiment besoin de main d'oeuvre dans
les champs ça c'est certain on a besoin
de moins de besoins de l'agriculture
mais dans ces conditions là je suis pas
certain qu'ils soient tous heureux y en
a quelques-uns dans la beauce qui peut
avoir des énormes exploitations et qui
font partie des lobbys mais ils sont
très peu nombreux on les compte sur les
doigts d'une main donc en réalité des
agriculteurs font tant de ce système ils
sont bien moins nombreux que ce qu'on
essaie de nous faire croire et je pense
que c'est vraiment au contraire associés
se rencontre aussi de qu'est ce qu'il ya
dans notre assiette douce et bien
commencé un peu c'est qu'il a produit et
mieux rémunéré nos agriculteurs français
d'agricultrice française redynamiser
aussi cesser ces métiers là est vrai
beaucoup de sens finalement je
coluche qui disaient les gens cherchent
pas forcément du travail de l'argent
leur suffirait moi je viens d'une région
dans lequel en fait il y avait les mines
les houillères à forbach et à stiring
wendel dans lequel on a les mines de
charbon non plus produit dans les deux
fautes de la france si on les a fermées
et il ya des milliers et des milliers de
personnes qui ont été mis à la retraite
en fait on leur a posé la question est
ce que ça te dit même à partir de 38 ans
tu avais la possibilité de passer à la
retraite est clairement si on va
aujourd'hui demandé à un certain nombre
de pêcheurs et un certain nombre de deux
agriculteurs en leur proposant on est
avec on éponge des dettes et on te
propose une retraite à partir de
désormais je suis assez convaincu qu une
énorme partie d un des éleveurs puisque
c'est les éleveurs ont un énorme
problématique relatifs à leurs revenus
prendrait cette option là sauf que ça ça
demande une implication politique qui
créerait un fonds permettant se
permettant justement ce passage là
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est enfin on
peut pas demander à une autre génération
à nous de faire de faire une meute de
prendre des mesures de cette façon là
c'est uniquement les politiques qui
pourraient le prendre quand oui c'était
juste pour ajouter là dessus sur la
pression financière aussi qui c'est pour
ça aussi que c'est une force politique
importante parce que il ya une vraie
pression financière c'est à dire que
l'agriculture industrielle on a dit
super idée vous inquiétez pas sortie
d'après guerre on essaie de de nourrir
tous les baby boomer de redynamiser
aussi l'économie française a répondu au
défi d'un temps peut-être mal ça a
répondu au défi d'antan simplement
maintenant c'est complètement caduque et
on se retrouve à voir des paysans des
agriculteurs qui sont endettés jusqu aux
dents parce qu'ils doivent louer les
machines et puis après les pesticides et
puis après ils sont dépendants quand on
a des prêts à la banque monumentaux
qu'on achète quelques centaines comme
quelques que qu'on a carrément des cours
pour le blé et que du coup on est on
achète nos denrées mais l'isère est bien
évidemment qu'en fait quand on dit en
plus de ça bah en fait c'est votre faute
vous devez tout arrêter comment est ce
qu'on fait donc c'est à dire que c'est
une question qui doit être politique et
ça ça se décide au niveau européen la
politique agricole commune qui a été
décidé il ya quelques semaines la était
un total d astrée on a encore dans du
coup c'est dans cinq ans on va pouvoir
négocier ça et là il ya des vraies
questions et pour moi c'est ici qu'on
doit mettre la farce mais vous comprenez
bien que pour des gens qui ont vécu
alors on rappellera ben toujours aux
trente glorieuses mais on a le souvenir
de la guerre aussi et puis on est
souvenir qu'après la guerre il a fallu
repartir à zéro et nourrir tout pays
puis nourrir les pays alentour puisqu'on
attend sans oublier mais avant la
seconde guerre mondiale je crois qu'il y
avait encore 40% de la preuve du plus
attractive qui était dans l'agriculture
je crois que c'est 60% ou voire 80%
avant la première guerre mondiale c'est
encore 25% après la seconde guerre
mondiale et puis aujourd'hui c'est 3% et
avec 3 % de la population active vous
nourrissez tout le monde et vous
exportez et on prie on ne rit comment je
veux dire regardez la santé après à
quelques enquêtes sa santé l'a surpris
de voir les écosystèmes sont fatigués
les agriculteurs comme engrais mais
l'espérance de vie l'espérance de vie
est ce qu'elle
est donc on dit tout simplement que
malheureusement si on touche à ce
système est ce qu'on va revenir aux
pénuries
je suis à pas jusqu'à la famine mais
pourquoi pas
c'est cette période d'abondance elle
était elle est très très jeune elle date
de très très peu de temps comptez est ce
que vous êtes en train de nous dire
c'est qu'il faut en sortir est
volontairement en fait c'est pas c'est
pas la dissolution pour avoir une
agriculture
juste et qui ne détruit pas les
écosystèmes et les gens qui la
produisent qui va créer des familles
c'est justement cette agriculture
industrielle qui est en train de nous
mener directement par des familles on a
là à madagascar la première flaminio
dérèglement climatique c'est les effets
de cette agriculture intensive qui crée
ensuite des catastrophes en chaîne et
donc des familles ne faut pas voir le
problème dans l'autre sens je dirai ce
que il s'agit pas de proposer aux gens
de sortir de l'abondance parce que ça
effectivement ça marche pas sur tout les
générations qui ont été traumatisés par
balle à 10 est la guerre et c'est donc
ça je dirais motionnaire mans on
comprend que il ya des blocages qui sont
qui sont très très fort donc il faut
proposer quelque chose d'autre il faut
proposer de la prospérité c'est à dire
qu'il faut il faut se poser la question
est ce qu'avec cette abondance les gens
sont heureux moi je ne suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui même les classes moyennes
supérieures dans ce pays là soit
particulièrement heureuse c'est des gens
qui sont stressés qui qui qui bosse
beaucoup voilà c'est des gens qui
d'ailleurs ne peuvent pas être heureux
dans un océan de malheurs donc la
question c'est pourquoi en remplace
enfin par contre en place ces flux
matériel puisqu'on nous a on a inculqué
que c'est la consommation qui faisait le
bonheur que c'est l'achat d'un bien
matériel qu'ils allaient faire le
bonheur en fait on se rend compte que
c'est pas vrai et les confinements aussi
en fait c'est les liens qui font le
bonheur c'est l'amour qu'on donne et
conçoit pour schématiser donc en fait
nan mais il ya une question très
pragmatique derrière c'est que la
prospérité c'est aussi les conditions
pour que chacun puisse tisser des liens
et s'épanouir dans la mais ça ça
présuppose une politique c'est à dire
que cela présuppose que l'état organise
les conditions de survie de chacun en
fait la base de la pyramide de maslow et
et voilà donc ça peut paraître un petit
peu un petit peu béni oui oui pour
certains qui sont dans le pragmatique
dans le matériel mais on a cette étude
de l'ademe qui date d'il ya quelques
années par exemple qui nous dit que deux
personnes qui vivent ensemble consomme
60 % moins d'énergie que deux personnes
qui vivent c'est à séparément a misé
ensemble pourquoi parce que quand on
manque d'affect en fait on compense
thermiquement en compensent ce manque
d'amour part de la chaleur ça peut
paraître voilà mon prend des douches
plus longues on met chauffage plus plus
plus élevés et l'étalement urbain en
fait est cinq fois plus rapide que
l'accroissement démographique en france
donc on construit des petits pavillons à
tout va on massacre les sols agricoles à
cause de ça parce que c'est des
changements de comportement c'est des
gens qui vivent plus en plus seul etc
etc
non mais aussi ses terres que où la mer
on vit dans un monde où les gens ont
peur les uns des autres ça c'est les
dégâts de la télévision aussi un puce x
3 fait divers en quinze ans au jt enfin
je veux dire on a tout un tas d'éléments
qui participent à l'atomisation de la
société mais il y aura pas de transition
écologique sans renouer avec avec du
vivre ensemble mais alors on parle très
souvent de consommation on vient de le
faire aux fins de l'évoquer sachant que
à peu près tout ce qu'il ya autour de
nous contient des résidus de pétrole un
peu près tout ce qu'on achète tous
comportent qui a duré du pétrole doit
absolument tout
alors on a tendance à condamner la
consommation vous n'êtes pas les
derniers d'ailleurs elle a condamné la
production la consommation réalité moi
c'est vraiment du côté de la production
qu'il faut qu'on fasse peser la
responsabilité c'est pas uniquement en
bout de chaîne parce que ce sera
beaucoup plus long donc plus injuste
s'il est bon c'est difficilement
demander l'admission à des producteurs
d'arrêter de produire ce que les gens
leur demande de produire justement mais
les producteurs imposent des goûts aux
consommateurs john dalli cité par le
traditionnel oui oui
alors prenons les choses d'un autre côté
pro qu'une consommation alors où votre
génération en revanche cela est très
très présente ses vêtements
dieu sait si les vêtements c'est très
mauvais écologiquement en tout cas d'en
changer beaucoup d'en acheter pas cher
etc etc à la limite un beau costume
qu'on garde plusieurs années ça coûte
moins cher écologiquement que toutes les
fringues pas cher que votre génération
adorent acheter
nos générations et donc être content
loubet c'est pour vous dire ce qu'on
attend de vous conseiller de faire sur
la viande est sûre les laitages moins de
vêtements
vêtements 100 g
alors évidemment il ya les vêtements
puis surtout alors bien pire bien pire
le numérique est là alors là vous êtes
en pointe pour envoyer des photos et
peut souvent des photos de chats aussi
des photos intéressantes à c'est pas la
question mais en fait dieu sait s'ils
cessaient de poudre le numérique quand
même il faut le savoir j'ai les chiffres
c'est ça représente en pollution toute
la flotte mondiale des camions toute la
flotte mondiale des camions qui viennent
pour le numérique c'est deux fois la
marine marchande celle qui arrive avec
les containers qui nous qui nous apporte
tout ce dont on a besoin des bas et bien
c'est bien pire le numérique et enfin
ces deux tiers de la pollution causée
par les voitures du monde entier
sont épouvantables ce chiffre était
moins de téléphones portables -
d'internet - d'ordinateurs - doute vous
savez et je pensais pas avoir cette
réponse à j'ai posé cette question au
cours des amis en disant on avait ce
débat là on parlait des chiffres et tout
ça et j'ai dit en réalité si vous n'êtes
absolument populaire ce que je veux dire
et je l'assumé totalement si on devait
limiter un nombre d'heures par par jour
avec accès à internet est ce que vous le
feriez tout démarre en fait oui si on
n'achète j'étais contraint je serais
pour en fait faire ça et d'ailleurs on
est beaucoup à avoir un temps d'écran à
voir mamie a maintenant des applications
pour limiter le temps parce que il ya
une question environnementale
énergétique très forte mais aussi une
question d'indépendance de penser une
question de l'addiction à une guerre de
l'attention parce que les algorithmes
eux font qu' on est conforté dans ce
qu'on pense en plus de ça bah ça nous
rend notre attention de concentration
ceva part constamment on dort beaucoup
moins bien que lumière de enfin ya tout
un tas de problèmes de santé publique
que pose le numérique et sk c'est dingue
c'est qu'on est quand même presque la
première génération où on a vu moi je me
sens déjà à vingt trois ans dit elle
avait à mon âge on n'avait pas laissé
les fans cheechoo a dressé dengue est
déjà là je vois de décalage donc on
n'avait pas les effets c'est super et
les effets c'est fou on va vivre en fait
ses effets du numérique délais très
jeune on est en train de vivre les
hommes habituellement aucun recul dessus
donc s'est
prononcé le mot c'est ainsi on dit est
contraint si on nous l'interdisait on
serait prêt à sacrifier sa tombe d'or
quand tu passes devant les écrans non
non on arrive toujours la même chose
aubry
d'en arriver au rationnement et je crois
que oui c'est la sobriété c'est à dire
aller vers du milieu et pas forcément
toujours du plus et je pense que dans
l'absolu c'est quand même le débat sur
la croissance et le pib du plus de pib
pour de plus de pib en réalité tout le
monde s'en fout vous demander ça à tous
les français et les françaises personne
va vous dire à part quelques dents
vraiment ça m'intéresse killer
intéresser plus d'égalité plus de
justice plus d'éducation plus de santé
enfin c'est ça qu'on parle pas c'est la
même chose sur tout le reste ils ont dit
on vous aurez accès à une meilleure
alimentation
vous aurez à des contenus de meilleure
qualité vous passerez des meilleurs
moments vous serez plus heureux mais bon
s'il patine des signaux faibles ça veut
dire en gros moi j'ai connu ça quand
j'étais enfant la télévision il y avait
une ou deux chaînes et elle s'arrêtait à
demi nue et
donc il très souvent d'ailleurs cette
belle génération pense que les
programmes était mieux avant c'est pas
forcément vrai jamais mais bon faut se
disent ah mais en gros ce que vous nous
proposez c'est ça c'est qu'on en
revienne à lower
tf1 avec l'écran s'allume
regardez à peu près tous la même chose
s'est passé
stratégie de la part de vous un tas
d'entreprises sur en numérique pour
garder l'attention des gens c'est une
guerre de la tension aujourd'hui
création numérique et donc il ya toute
cette stratégie d'entreprise pour nous
faire scrollé plus longtemps pour nous
faire cliquer sur sur tel lien pour nous
enfin pour feu passé telle pub dans nos
fil d'actualité facebook instagram tik
tok est
en fait à un moment donné il est très
très difficile d'aller voir les
consommateurs ou de facebook instagram
tik tok à la fin en leur disant c'est
vous le problème qui restait très
longtemps quand derrière ça il ya toute
une stratégie pour les faire garder plus
longtemps nous on a vraiment sa dent au
niveau du plastique on avait un peu la
même problématique c'est que on essaie
de faire des tutos zéro déchet essayer
de montrer vraiment quelles sont les
passes et un mode de vie zéro déchet
quand on passe dans un hypermarché ou un
supermarché aujourd'hui il ya du
plastique partout comment est-ce qu'on
peut enfin c'est très très compliqué
pour enfin pour nous d'aller voir et
dire ok il faudrait consommer sans
plastique quand l'offre en face est
entièrement plastifiées
c'est ce que ça veut dire qu'on se
blesse en plastique c'est quoi ce but
beaucoup plus cher
développé autour de ça ouais mais en
fait c'est si c'était un choix
évidemment que non un agité même j'ai vu
dans un il y avait des des bananes qui
était en bambou loupé en plus dans du
plastique je veux dire c'est qu'on est
quand même complètement perdu la bou
quoi c'est la nature est fait pour les
états unis mais tous ou presque y met du
coup en réalité le coût ne devrait pas
être plus important parce que
précisément il ya de la matière en moins
il ya deux
mois j'ai connu l'époque on faisait ses
courses y avait pas de bouteilles en
plastique j'étais petit c'était très
lourd à porter
le rire des arguments de sécurité donc
là en l'occurrence il faut emballer des
bananes parce que vous comprenez on les
protège mieux l'extérieur en fait on
vend tout enfin je veux dire c'est aussi
une inflation des normes
qui sous couvert de sécurité et
d'hygiène nous plastifiée la vie m'ont
pour en revenir sur cette question du
rationnement et notamment des flux
internet le problème c'est que ceux qui
font ça actuellement c'est la chine qui
interdisent aux enfants de plus de 40
minutes de jeu vidéo par jour je suis
pas sûr que ce soit ce qu'on veut et
d'engins dans une période où avec la
politique sanitaire qui est très
agressive etc on a un resserrement sur
les libertés fondamentales on a le
contrôle de l'information parce que
maintenant si vous si vous publiez
quelque chose sur la pandémie vous êtes
strike et par les algorithmes
directement sur instagram facebook etc
je suis pas sûr que si on dit ça on ça
va résonner positivement dans la tête
des gens moi ce que j'observe c'est que
[Musique]
je suis d'accord mais je suis d'accord
avec ce que vous dites tous les deux
c'est à dire qu'on a on a des
entreprises de l'attak qui travaillent
sur le conditionnement et sur la
libération de la dopamine par
l'optimisation des algorithmes sur les
réseaux sociaux donc en fait c'est le la
dopamine c'est l'hormone du bonheur
c'est se situe à eur comment est-ce
qu'on va drogué le consommateur derrière
il ya tout un tas d'intérêts financiers
mais la bonne la bonne nouvelle quand on
étudie un petit peu le cerveau c'est que
le cerveau libère aussi de la dopamine
quand on accumule de la connaissance à
part enfin voila quand on accumule
évidemment de la matière mais aussi
quand on accumule de la connaissance
donc toute la question c'est qu'est ce
qu'on propose et aussi comment est-ce
qu'on rend has been des chorégraphies
sur tik tok parce que bon voilà il ya
des effets de mode qui ont un poids
carbone voilà les photos de chatons et
xterra comment est-ce qu'on peut rendre
hype disons je sais pas moi des sorties
en forêt le fait de tisser des liens et
c'est encore une fois ça peut paraître
un peu j ai dit comme ça mais pour moi
la clé de la transition elle est aussi
là mais vous vous rendez bien compte que
on sait comment fonctionne le
capitalisme on vous met sur le marché un
certain nombre de choses qu'on essaye de
rendre le plus attrayante possible et
puis quand ya beaucoup de consommateurs
qui s'y accrochent et bien l'entreprise
marche fait fortune rachète
éventuellement même d'autres entreprises
enfin on connaissait par coeur vous
voudriez et on voit bien que les
français s'y sont pas mis volonté
d'ailleurs lesessarts doute un des pays
les moins gros capitalistes du monde et
mai mais on n'aime pas trop la
concurrence on aime bien les services
publics etc etc il embête demeure pas
moins que si vous voulez remplacer sa
part une autorité qui vient nous dire un
peu comme d'autres fois on n'a droit
qu'à tombeur de télé par jour on a le
droit de quatre temps de 14 le nombre de
grammes de viande par semaine etc etc
en gros c'est peu l'idée que l'on peut
s'en faire en tout cas les gens de ma
génération c'est une dictature et au
fond je vois pas je vois pas quelle est
l'alternative pour au fond réalisé ce
que vous souhaitez est ce que semble
nécessiter le changement climatique nous
ne voyons pas d'autre alternative que
les dictatures vous avez l'air de la
souhaitait alors que l'on nous fait peur
ce soit la démocratie et aux contrats
d'achats montrent une dictature la
démocratie vous y allez demander à les
demander à ajustement la convention
citoyenne dont je vous parlais qu'avait
des mesures très radicale 1 allait
demander le pourcentage de français qui
étaient favorables à ces mesures il plus
de la majorité des français qui
souhaitaient ça allait moins m'en
demandez autour de vous qui est content
du monde dans lequel on vit et qui
souhaitent que le statu quo reste les
chiffres seront bien moins importante
qu'en fait ce qu'il faut se dire c'est
que le monde dans lequel on vit n'a pas
l'approbation de l'intégralité des
citoyens et des citoyennes donc en fait
proposer une autre alternative ce n'est
pas forcément l'imposé c'est la choisir
ensemble et ce qu'on essaie de dire
c'est que il va y avoir des changements
malheureusement ne peut pas négocier
avec les degrés qui s'envole avec
l'élite planétaire on doit faire avec
voilà on on a une vie se trouve qu'elle
a des limites on meurt à la fin pas
pareil la terre à la des limites c'est
comme ça on peut trouver ça triste c'est
simplement ainsi peut-être qu'il arrange
joly est intéressante sinon on serait
quand même un petit peu long il
commencera à s'ennuyer donc quelque part
c'est intégrer ça dans notre modèle de
société aussi et démocratiquement se
poser la question de comment est-ce
qu'on veut habiter monde quelle manière
d'être vivant on a envie de mettre en
place ensemble et c'est pas forcément
quelque chose de triste de 2,2 de doué
de pas souhaitable ça peut être très
bien on a fini est-ce que vous rappelez
la première revendication des gilet
jaune c'était le rétablissement du sf
c'est à dire que ce qui avait le havre
c'était d'abord de ne pas augmenter le
nombre de la première revendication
politique était formulée pour le plateau
c'était ça parce qu'on ne supportait pas
qu'en fait il ya des gens qui jouent pas
le jeu voilà si on joue tout ce jeu
parce que c'est c'est le produit d'un
choix démocratique comme le dit bien
camille je pense que beaucoup de gens
seront seront contents de restreindre
certains types de consommation et le
sondage de ifop fractures françaises de
2 cette année le montre bien 82 % des
français sont prêts enfin aimerait que
le gouvernement prenne des mesures un
peu forte quitte à ce que ça change leur
mode de vie donc la tante elle est là
mais il faut que ça soit faut que ça
s'accompagne d'une d'une égalité de fait
que tout le monde joue je
débattrai
merci tous les frogs va participer à
cette émission merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]